the agenda is said hello everyone I
print gough in Berlin the world is
focused on the US city of Boston to bomb
explosions near the finish line of the
Boston Marathon the White House saying
it is treating the blast as a terror
attack our reporters are in Boston and
Washington DC we will have the latest
coming up on the journal at the top of
the hour well today on agenda The Iron
Lady of the Western world is dead should
we put Thatcherism to rest with her that
in more today it is time to talk when
Margaret Thatcher spoke to Parliament
like this is prime minister she was
changing British society many say
forever her economic policies unleashed
rage and adoration but are they a fix
for today's problems in Germany a trial
is set to begin zoo that will force the
country to once again examine how and
why the ideology of the Nazis can endure
a suspected neo-nazi the lone survivor
of a terror group is accused in a series
of murders aimed mostly at foreigners
today we talk about what the case itself
says about Germany's fight to stop the
far right and if you've never met a Jew
the Jewish Museum here in Berlin can
change that but you should know it's not
over a cup of tea a new exhibit is
raising ire and eyebrows a Jew in the
Box a living jus answering questions
about Judaism is this simply an Orthodox
culture will learning critics call it a
circus acts well I've invited three
people today to talk argue and pry apart
these headlines my first guest is a Jew
and he has spent some time in that box
at the Jewish Museum in Berlin I'm happy
to welcome to the show bill glue croft
is a business consultant Billy you moved
to Berlin three years ago from the US
you say yourself that Jews are a
curiosity you say we shouldn't try to
deny that
so I'm wondering how does putting you as
a Jew in a box to answer questions from
strangers how does that change or lessen
the fact that Jews are a curiosity
speaking of course only from my
impressions of sitting in that box I'd
say the goal is not at first to lower
the the curiosity of Jews but simply to
confront the fact that people think and
see Jews as a curiosity and many Jews
feel themselves as a curiosity in
society we're going to talk about that
feeling in just a moment glad to have
you on the show my second guest is one
of Germany's leading defense attorneys
in cases involving criminal criminal law
and foreigners I'm happy to welcome to
the show mr. Klaus Rudra he is an
attorney who has represented defendants
in cases involving Islamists and the
Kurdish PKK group here in Germany mr.
rooter is good to have you on the show
you say this case now is not surprising
and the way things have run because you
say police and security forces in
Germany are not trained properly to
sniff out far-right criminals how is
that possible well there's a provincial
communication to fight international or
nationwide terrorism and that's the
reason so there are bad communication
complicated communication and a lack of
ideas that means the in the criminal
case the police starts with a hypothesis
what could have happened to how the
thing could have started and nobody had
the idea of right terrors okay but we're
going to talk about changing that
hypothesis in just a second and my third
guest is one of Europe's leading
economist he is an adviser to Germany's
trade unions and he says at its core
thatcherism is spot on I'm happy to
welcome professor Gustav horn he is also
an advisor to the Social Democrat Party
here in Germany professor Warren it's
good to see you on the show what about
Thatcherism
you